[Music]
an Instagram parenting news submitted by
booze cruise a mommy influencer is
defending her 175 dollar online
parenting course after followers
questioned its legitimacy wait what so I
think she's teaching a class on
parenting and it's 175 bucks
and I think people are like what makes
you the authority Oh Blaine it oh she's
a parent and she's like cuz I'm a mother
I guess the authority is yep she's a
parent and if people feel like they want
to pay it no she do can I just say I
love that credential like when people go
like well I should know I am a mother
like they're taking out their [ __ ]
badge or something we're all supposed to
be like holy [ __ ] I've never seen one of
those before is that real parenting
blogger she's based in Australia but
she's from London so her name is
Courtney
Adamo she's a mother of five children oh
[ __ ]
well she does have a lot of experience
that's my mom for 14 years hardest job
in the world it really is the laboring
she's an expert in laboring popping out
kids there you go
so about a year and a half ago she liked
her whole family they left their home in
London to travel with their kids around
the world they went from Tokyo to Sri
Lanka Wow bless her heart that shit's
tough to LA as a single mom I just
wanted her to be a single mom hard to
top of the world single mom yeah that's
even harder true so now she documents
all of her family aspects and their
travels on Instagram where she has
almost 250,000 followers and so it's
good about recently she introduced an
online lifestyle and parenting course
that she's named in the loop and so let
me show you some photos if you have five
kids and you travel the world I want to
learn from her right this is what I
learn there
where's the mom at they all literally
the family like in pit frames that's a
very diverse you know yes you can say
thank you every time I see one person
with brown hair one person blonde yeah
every time I see white families I'm like
y'all a related yeah they never look
alike cuz it back the little boy a super
blonde hair then the mom has all she
could probably diet the dad has like
yeah you want to see strong genetics
look at a Chinese family male or female
they have the same exact face and then
if the hair is just different alright so
I'm gonna show you guys this video of
her promoting her course if there's
anything I've learned in the 14 years
I've been a mother it's that the
parenting journey is an ever evolving
100 we have all have new faces and face
new challenges
toddlers turn into teenagers in the
blink of an eye and just when you think
you've mastered parenting you're faced
with a whole new set of parenting issues
through the highs and lows of family
life it's wonderful to have an open mind
to ask questions and to seek wisdom from
others through this collaborative course
I'm excited to share learn and grow
together
[Music]
how does a shot really nice the
beautiful house living lighting
[Applause]
[Music]
I look forward to welcoming you in the
loop why do I feel like the dad owns
like a scuba business where tourists
come and he teaches them how to like do
scuba diving and then like the mom home
schools the kids and then they always
burn sage and [ __ ] but then they're not
that hippie like they're still like kind
of like what do you call it like middle
class I just see a social media house am
I crazy I see a social media house it is
yeah it's very Instagram yeah I
Instagram Abul exactly so when I see the
sage though I see the same yeah the sage
burning yep
so this is like I'm gonna show you guys
a comment and this is pretty much what
the feedback is it's not all negative
but the negative side is what this is
what they're saying so it says will the
course deal with issues such as bringing
up children in a privileged bubble or
white privilege worldwide and especially
in Australian history so that's what
people that's why people were kind of
writing her off as like seriously like
you you're raising your children in this
bubble but us this sounds kind of like a
hater because parents are gonna produce
white children what the [ __ ] were they
talking about do they expect the Asian
baby to pop out of that [ __ ] so there's
nothing about how she's been so
fortunate in her life and like how she's
able to just quit her job and travel the
world and like now do this and why are
they assuming there's a lot of
assumptions because they're also
assuming that her husband is a
stay-at-home dad which she says that
he's not he's a scuba instructor yeah
you know that he sells flip-flops by the
shore I had surfing lessons from a guy
that looked like that
he works five days a week as a managing
director at a Melbourne based animation
company oh cool um and so she was just
saying that you know people always ask
me questions about how I deal with
raising my kids and so I thought I could
create this course for people that were
asking so she's just kind of like damn
guys chill like I'm trying to do my
thing yeah yeah feel like she did
nothing wrong she's just trying to do
her thing and the people are getting
criticized you or something she can't
control how awesome that video was made
me start looking for imperfection
because everything was too perfect from
the [ __ ] clothes to the house to
their genetics like everything I was
like you as in beauty right not now not
just cuz they're white but like like I
was like how the [ __ ] is this they look
like a picture perfect dude they have to
put vaseline on the lens bro like that
[ __ ] was like foggy Oprah lighting man
so another feature film of just a family
living life another comment that they
highlighted and this article says I
don't really get it you've always seemed
very down-to-earth to me so it surprises
me a bit that you'd be charging $250
it's Australian dollars for what is
essentially tips on how to live your
personal how to live your personal sort
of lifestyle isn't family lifestyle
something we want to each develop with
our own families rather than copying
someone else's you don't have to do it
[ __ ] it nobody's making you buy it you
[ __ ] idiot thank you Jesus
these people are crazy they're all so
stupid because so I'll look up [ __ ] for
parenting right because I'm like I'm
like sometimes I am like well how do
other people do it just cuz that's me I
have all the answers okay next time I'll
do that but like you want to hear other
people's point of views and perspectives
and things that they've tried that
they've succeeded or failed eggs and
that way we can learn faster so I'll
look at people's and vlogs always pop up
right so then I'll look it up and I'm
pretty sure these parents that are
complaining or whatever people that are
complaining they might not even be
parents they go to the same blog and
they don't even realize that they're
also the bloggers getting money for it
because there's ads being posted and
[ __ ] so there's no difference and like
if you're getting this information why
should it be free and if you know took
the time to create a course why not sell
it yeah of course yeah cuz you know how
hard I mean you make Kaizen and all that
stuff like you know how hard it is to
make an educational course you have to
put thought behind how do i progress
someone that might not know you know
some of the stuff that i do like if they
like how do you bring someone up from
scratch that takes a lot of time with
different between this and a book why
would you buy a book but and paper that
but not let's take it all the way there
like it's like you go why don't you walk
into a Lamborghini dealership whoever's
buying a car smack keys
like aren't you lucky enough as it is
you live in a privilege so whatever the
[ __ ] it's just you can take this all the
way to the end of the earth I think I
have to see the program first to even
judge it like I don't I feel like if if
they didn't even buy the product or
anything like that how can you even
comment and review something that you
haven't even seen yet so another thing
is to is there so she said people claim
that I have a full-time housekeeper and
a full-time nanny in reality we went
without any childcare babysit a
babysitter
nanny or a housekeeper from the time we
left London until 2015 in 2015 until
just last year when we hired a cleaner
for four hours per week so that's just
like a little bit bigger because the
video was so dope I started getting
jealous and I don't even have a family
it was so [ __ ] dope I'm like judging
like man I bet you there they have like
nice dinners where they have the nice
perfectly rectangle cut salmon that's
got like [ __ ] garnish on it and it's
always picture-perfect and I'm like they
probably have a picture-perfect ass dog
that never sheds and [ __ ] I'm like and
then somehow they have a dog we didn't
they have perfect colleges and I'm like
[ __ ] these how did that I mean where
does she even find a time like someone's
meeting someone yeah and she's well done
let me finish reading the comments I
started reading earlier the one that's
clearly very much hating this so to
continue they wrote I totally get that
this isn't going to be a community that
this is going to be a community and
include interviews etc because of
because of course we all need that
collaborative engagement where when it
comes to family but I just don't
understand when we started to when we
started to pay people to dictate to us
how to live cook decorate and parent
it's not that I dislike the idea of
bloggers monetizing their blogs and of
course you are a businesswoman
it just seems an odd thing to make into
a business that's how what are you
[ __ ] talking about
it's a family platform like that's her
whole brand right that's yeah and if
you're watching her because you enjoy
her lifestyle wouldn't you want to
replicate it in your own life I feel
like that people that are upset probably
don't even support this lady anyway
because I feel like when stuff like this
happens random people just start coming
up and they watch the video they're just
like
yeah that one comment that I was reading
though in the beginning and seemed like
they were following her cuz they were
like you always seemed so very
down-to-earth to me I'm just surprises
me that you're gonna charge us now this
is like people were like biggest JK fan
ever you know and they make a new
account or whatever and then they're
like hey I don't like you guys anymore
whatever the [ __ ] you know I'm saying
people do that [ __ ] all the time like to
[ __ ] with people yeah they have to make
a big announcement just to let you know
that they used to love you but they
don't anymore like I'm gonna go unfollow
it's like okay it's like damn I feel
like everything is enough for everybody
because I don't have to guys thought
James Charles was charging like I don't
know five hundred for meet-and-greet it
was a VIP yeah yeah yeah and people got
upset and they're like why are you
charging this much like we can't afford
this and then like it sold out because
like it's not for you that can't afford
it somebody imported it like someone's
gonna use this lady's service like if
you don't want to okay move it on yeah
you've got it somebody it's gonna you
them I think it's because when she when
this happens right what ends up
happening is like I start hating her
because now I have to clean up my house
cuz I know I can do it I know I want it
to look that way and now she's making me
want to work and that's the same [ __ ]
with Fitness and like programs I'm just
like [ __ ] you I want to eat what I want
to eat but I want to look good too but
you there must be some kind of cheating
that you're doing cheaters yeah they
probably got that house on like peer
space is that even there how are you
watch it is oh my god I even hate them
even more it's it's not a fact that they
could travel with that meanie and they
don't even stress I hope one one of
them's cheating on the other one and
they're like five minutes
kids got social problems and [ __ ] hope
something's happening they're hard you
want to see some real [ __ ] - that guy
was like cutting the vegetables while
smiling at his wife we want to see him I
cut into his finger [ __ ] bloodsport
now he's nuts going like this at the
footage I want to see them like spank
the [ __ ] out of their kids because
they're not performing well on camera
and then like every time the camera
comes out they have to like whip them
into shape and like it's like it's like
what it's like the Jacksons like what
Joe Jackson did to Michael Jackson but
like that's what this is happening here
his family [ __ ] trolls are over yeah
so we compete chillax
low-key no and that's how I feel the
chosen I can get into their head because
that's that's what a lot of people are
doing they don't know that they're doing
that but that's exactly what what's
going on here why would you have such a
negative reaction to towards something
like this yeah it's you can't just look
at and go oh that's nice yeah maybe I'll
try it or not or just be like good for
her like she's doing her thing yeah but
I mean if I was a mother though and I
saw a mother of five [ __ ] do this
[ __ ] and I'm like yo I'm doing something
wrong cuz I'm a mother of one and I
don't know how to [ __ ] do this right
maybe she knows something that I don't
so I'm saying we only won it affects me
too I get pissed what actually somebody
buy a Lamborghini doesn't bother me when
I see somebody go buy me a Lamborghini
make gun it and I'm like walking by this
tree and it's in my ear Thomas I'm like
you're a [ __ ] dick dude you know I
mean like that's one [ __ ] when you cross
into my lane that's what I get even
though she's gotten like all this hate
and stuff 300 people have already signed
up for her Oh a week course I want to
sign up weeks it's a five week course
it's voluntary too man Jesus every 175
for five weeks you can't even go to UCB
for five weeks for $175 that's like
we're pliable exactly yeah yeah please
teach me how to travel the world with
five kids yeah aren't we just one pound
child ruled by myself honey no I do that
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Music]